i'm taylor zakar perez and i'm going
undercover
on the internet this is actually me
[Music]
first up twitter
[Music]
jenny said wait joey king and taylor
zakar prez are actually dating in real
life
exclamation exclamation exclamation
question mark
okay let me process that with four a's
a sad face and a heart joey king and i
are not dating i love her dearly
but no we are not dating we might take
trips together but
no next question
where has the world been hiding hashtag
taylor zakar perez and
how did netflix find him like damn thank
you
very much for that comment that's um
made my day
thank you and they found me because i
auditioned for them like a hundred times
so
they finally said yes so thank you
netflix i appreciate you
and vince the director and michelle i
mean and joey my god
back to joey that's why you guys think
we're dating because we talk about each
other all the time
all right i won't talk about her anymore
i don't do twitter i'm not on twitter i
don't think i've ever
tweeted anything i feel like twitter's a
dark place so
i try to stay out of there i'm a pretty
happy person i don't need anyone on
twitter to bring me down
alright alright youtube
love me some youtube i had an interview
with mtv
jessalyn says he was born on christmas
wtf i'm in love
jessalyn i hate to burst your bubble but
i was born on christmas eve
many hours from christmas day but i was
sent home in a santa claus suit
so that was exciting i was a very ugly
baby like i'm not gonna lie i was
red like beat red and when my mom shows
pictures of me
to people or friends i get really
embarrassed because i was
not a cute baby there's a lot of cute
babies out there i was not one of them
sorry mom moving on aditi said
the fact that he's read all the harry
potter books and he's so passionate
about them makes him
10 times more attractive lol no lol i
love harry potter
all the books i've read them all twice
i'll read them again i'll challenge you
to read them again i love harry potter
what a world what world to be in like
that special effects were
at that level when i was a kid that i
got to experience like the real harry
potter
i feel like everyone thinks they should
be in gryffindor just cuz i've taken
many tests
i've eaten all the birdie bots i
reflavored beans and they put the
sorting hat on my head and it said
gryffindor as well so you know
i didn't just like choose it it chose me
i have a wand yeah
moving on flawsy is it just me or does
taylor and jacob
lowkey look alike because it's been
bothering me so much because i see it
1.9 000 likes where all my dislikes at i
mean i'll take it he's a handsome guy
you know
thank you but low-key we look alike i
will say i've done like a comparison
with a photographer friend of mine
because he just stares at faces all day
and we just put our hands on the face
different parts and we
landed that maybe this part of us
looks the same the eyes and the eyebrows
i guess elle evans has a type
i guess i'm like the browner version of
jacob
i don't know all right
on the trailer this is a lot of
consonants next to each other i can't
pronounce this name
maybe it's her name backwards ammos it's
awesome backwards
okay nevermind with an n awesome and
but front ways wait let me get this
straight you want me to watch the
kissing boot 2
all alone stuck at home with no one to
kiss netflix why
why 10 miso two crying faces
this is actually pretty funny we should
do live readings of youtube comments
because that'd be
pretty hysterical i'm really sorry that
you have no one at home to watch this
with
i think there's zoom parties house party
you can you could do that
maybe i'll skype you is skype's still a
thing i don't know i'll zoom you and we
can
watch it together and we can talk all
about it but we'd have to fast forward
to minute 20 because that's when i get
in there
and you know it's like who wants to
watch the first 20 minutes of that
right replied all right this is my
favorite platform let's let's move over
to instagram
instagram's a bit of a kinder kinder
place
okay so i posted this video and i said
text me right
it's chloe wait does he actually end up
answering and the answer is yes
i do i i mean i'll show you on on my
phone right now
i'm gonna tell you how many people have
texted me 110 078 people
have text me you know what since we're
here there's some birthdays today
so let's take a selfie
that's like major cheese but you know
i'm gonna use this photo
and say happy birthday we are filming
a gq segment and i wanted
to share the love
let's see what that does we'll check
back in chloe to answer your question i
do end up answering
maybe it was your birthday today and i
just said happy birthday i hope it was
that'd be cool
yes oh okay this is a picture of me
and my dog jack it's your girl lodi
wants to know his name i guess i just
spoiled it uh it's jack
he's the best he goes everywhere with me
i just went surfing with him the other
day
paddle boarded for two hours and he was
stressed he's a water dog
i need to get him another life jacket
all right let's see if anyone responded
they're quick these these folks are
quick oh okay here we go
thank you thank you thank you thank you
i'm really excited thanks how did you
know it's my birthday
hi thank you now i feel special bro
you're welcome joseph
thank you oh can i have you for my
birthday
[Music]
no no you can't
okay we're we're gonna put this away all
right next imdb
all right taylor was a nationally ranked
swimmer
true i was i swam for 10 years and i
don't like swimming now anytime i smell
chlorinated water it just like brings me
back to 5 am
practices and i just never want to go
back there but yes i was nationally
ranked
state champion loved it while i was
there loved all my friends he began his
journey in
opera houses performing musical theater
at an early age which ultimately led him
to pursue his film and television career
that is also true yeah i did like local
theater stuff
i did opera houses for some reason when
i see this as
his journey in opera houses like i feel
like i'm a you know like in the olden
days when those
horses and buggies would come to town
and then you just put all your stuff
out and you like do a song and dance
that's what i feel like
this is saying his journey in opera
houses but yeah that was it it was fun
you know it's like what do you do
after you're in theater in your
community it's like you just want to
like level up in a way so like i went to
chicago and auditioned there and worked
a little bit there and then
moved to los angeles moved to new york
moved back to los angeles and i think
i'm going to stay in los
angeles submit
quora is that how you say it quora
who is hotter taylor lautner or taylor
zakar perez
these are the sub sections taylor
lautner actor
hot guys hollywood actors attractive men
hollywood actors and actresses
plus five more uh can i can i answer it
there's
if i sign in as someone else i could
probably answer this question but
i just feel like that's not right that's
that's that's not nice taylor lautner is
also a handsome guy
jacob lordy you know like i guess i'm in
good company so
thank you whoever asked that question i
think these are anonymous so
you got away this time i grew up
watching taylor lautner i thought the
funniest thing was um
shark boy and lava girl that was an
interesting one yeah
all right another one is netflix making
a kissing booth three that's a good one
you know that's like
a little less invasive yes i'm just i
feel like that came off
really um aggressive i'm sorry yes so we
are making kissing boot 3. we actually
made it
last year we kind of had to fib about it
which was really hard i really enjoyed
filming the third one and i can't wait
for you guys to watch it
and i don't want to get sued so i'm not
going to say anything more
next oh another quora do you think that
l should have ended up with noah or
marco in the kissing boot too
come on this is all you got no i'm just
kidding i
definitely think that he and elle should
have wound up together i mean marco's
just a great guy you know he's
he's cool he's an artist musician
he's a nice guy i mean nice guys are
cool
you know your parents want you to bring
home nice guys especially at 17
18 years old so i would say marco but i
guess the heart wants what it wants
okay read it now this is where it gets
uh
a little scary the kissing booth 2
discussion okay
discuss the movie here from gluten-free
waffles
with a z can we talk about the cheating
situation between
l and noah did noah emotionally cheat on
l with chloe was l actually the cheater
because she kissed marco
what are your thoughts i want to know
first i want to say thank you
gluten-free waffles for saying that
elle kissed marco because that's a big
deal
you know i think it's a huge deal that
she yes
had a boyfriend that she may not have
been in love with anymore and might have
been falling in love with marco
so a kiss could have been warranted you
know what i mean but regardless
still cheating after i watched the the
first movie honestly i didn't think that
noah and elle would stay together since
he was going to college so
good for you noah for for having some
self-control
yes like she clearly cheated on noah
with marco but
i'm not mad at it you know i think
that's really i think that was a smart
choice
next kissing booth 23 am i the only one
who thinks she should end up with lee
no you're not i think she should end up
with lee too i
love lee and i love joel courtney he's
the best
i've been rooting for lee since the
first movie okay when we're at the lunch
table and i say to lee like there
there's no way she's going to want to do
it he says yes but then he does its
thing where he's like
and then like this fun music starts like
how can you not love lee in that moment
he's just like a golden retriever and he
should have everything he should have
all the ladies
because i just i love him
all right that's it that was weird all
right that's it
i am signing off the internet check me
out in kissing boot 3
i don't know when it comes out you're
gonna have to ask netflix but uh i hope
i answered some of your questions so
cool i do that a lot it means hang loose
it's just
it's like second nature to me now